how do you plan to write a story you
make a big mess and then try to pluck
the good stuff out I sit down with a
legal pad and I write down little tiny
BIOS lines basic stories conflicts
secrets all that kind of stuff and I
don't like like it's not neat like
they're circles and lines and scribbles
and stuff text out and and I only use
one side so I can just keep going and
then I will go back through and okay
that's kind of interesting that sort of
good that's kind of interesting all this
stuff I'll get to and I know I have
stacks of yellow legal pads that are
from products and like with the vampire
mob I had to I had to I never plan on
writing how the main character became a
vampire because I wanted it was a
screenwriting thing of starting as late
in the scene as you can so I wanted to
start after he was a man part when his
mother-in-law moved in for eternity I
thought that was more fun so in the
vampire mob issue - I have a little 10
page mini comic that is the origin story
of the main character so this is him
before he was a vampire and why he
became a vampire and it was something I
never shot before and so I'm writing the
comic book and I go back to the legal
pads from 2009 2010 and I'm going
through and I'm like oh yeah that thing
that's where I'm gonna go and a boom
just found a way to do it and it was
literally a wine that ended up in season
long that was something about doing the
whole light at the end of the tunnel
thing and I'm like walks in the tunnel
what's in the tunnel and that was enough
to just go so I think when you're
building a story is you're you know your
character has to want something officer
goes and all that stuff but I also think
like
you have to have fun making the
character do stuff like it's the old get
your character in a tree and throw rocks
at them like this should be fun for the
audience this should be fun for you this
should be fun like if it's drudgery like
I never felt like a drudgery when I was
reading except for one screenplay
because it wasn't my idea and sorry to
interject wait you said secrets hmm from
your time as a private investigator did
you start to realize how important
secrets are to what makes up a character
what drives people I guess when I worked
as a private investigator I had to call
people pretending to be someone who
didn't exist using a name that wasn't
mine calling from a company that wasn't
real with a story that was completely
made-up so I could get information
social engineering social engineering so
that is a hard thing to teach someone
how to do and I almost think it's kind
of him like you have to learn in the
trenches so I I guess what I learned
being a private investigator was it's
like being a con man it's a confidence
game so I could change my voice change
how fast I talk change my tone I would
always say my name the company where I
was calling from because if you give all
the information out front then they're
like ok and then you start giving them
the [ __ ] and then you start throwing
them what I call mr. X which are
questions that you do not need the
answers to because you have to stack up
the conversation to be thick enough to
not have those questions light up like
why is he asking me this because it's
like all these other questions and all
this thing just driving you drop it in
and kind of ride the conversation like a
wave and you just drop stuff in and
sometimes you're like I gotta force this
way even sometimes it work
sometimes it doesn't but I am a really
good liar
I guess and I and it was storytelling I
was telling people's stories I was
making up you know I had my lines down
and sometimes you know people would come
back come at me and I would have to come
up with another story on the spot and be
able to cover it so I was I was
investigating a guy who was in court
with the client so I we used to call
these cases the crazy [ __ ] because this
is a crash and burn you go in you either
get the information or you don't this
guy's in court he's gonna know most
likely that you are calling from the
other side because he's in court so I
call from the other side got a great
thing and this guy starts slamming me
he's like what's what's the phone number
I give him the phone what's the main
number for your company I don't know the
main number well how do you work at a
company not know the main number ah sir
I'm a temp I walked in there this
morning they put me down at a cubicle
I'm sitting down I have this phone
number right here so what I need to do
is get off the phone with you get on the
phone with my manager ask him what that
phone number is then I will call you
back with that number is that a right
sir yes so I hang up I call another
investigator here's the deal the name of
the company is this you're my boss this
is what we do click call the guy back
okay sir here's the number oh you know
I'm just in the middle of this whole
thing with lawyers and I just thought
you're one of them what did you need to
know
blah blah blah gives me everything I
need to know because the suspension of
disbelief is a real thing it happens in
the real world so they suspend their
disbelief that I'm not who I say I am
and they give me information that why in
god's name would I be asking that so the
story so you have to know who they are
to figure out who you are because you've
got to figure out some something that is
either not symbiotic at all or
potentially symbiotic because you need
some some reason it's either I need
something from you maybe you need
something from me we're gonna help each
other out
it's
[Music]
social engineering so having been on I
don't wanna say that side but having
been aware of some of that and now we're
in this new age of people's secrets
coming out and it's instant on on social
media do you feel that that's an
integral part to doing a backstory on a
character yeah I think the when I was
working as a PI I knew people were at
Google and I knew that we needed to keep
track of all the pretext to make sure
nothing got burnt so if a pretext gets
burnt it means they somebody has figured
out exactly what happened they know
exactly who did it they knew they were
lied to they know they know the whole
deal and they go online with it then
that's burnt you can't use that anymore
that story's garbage now because
somebody else is gonna google it they're
gonna find it it's an antique you've
gotta change up your names you got to
change up your your story no what was
the question
so just secrets being an important part
of a character's backstory into
characters motives and a characters arc
yeah I think there are things about like
characters in vampire mob even the
characters in play shorts the other
series I made that I know about them
that nobody else knows and no one else
will know like I know there's a big
overarching thing with vampire mom and I
know what it's about and no one else
does and I know at the end is and I
don't know if anyone else will ever know
or need to know but I wrote I wrote an
hour and 15-minute third season screen
time so I'm translating that into comic
books so I have I have a lot of stuff
written that's already done so I have
all these secrets that I'm getting to
sort of drag into more stories and some
that we haven't that we will learn
actually so you think that's okay to do
with characters to have the writer has
their secrets in the back pocket they
have their own file on them so to speak
yeah but the audience isn't privy to
that networks yeah I think I think the
audience the writer needs to know more
about the character than the audience
will ever know or could know because
you're not gonna have the time to
explain all this [ __ ] about them so if
you have you know remember it was a
psychology thing of like where you are
when you're sixteen is pretty close to
who you are
most of the developments happen not that
there's going you know more education
changes maturity all the rest of it but
the baseline is about there at sixteen
so you take your character to sixteen if
everything is there what happened to put
it there so it's literally just going
back and okay well if they're if they're
doing this and they're in this kind of
job or in this kind of situation then
they most likely came from this kind of
background that would bring him into
this world
oh and then you sort of reverse engineer
and then go back because sometimes I
think my mistake was not knowing enough
about characters when I started writing
stuff I knew like I thought I knew bare
bones about the character and I need to
know way more and I and I don't mean you
like to like we're an entire bio but you
need to know a bunch of stuff about
these people because when you're writing
about them and they're saying something
and the other character says something
and their response is specific because
of who they are specific and because the
secret you know it's fuels that response
if you don't know that and maybe it will
come out in the screenplay
or whatever the presentation you're
using but it's it's the work that actors
do when if I give an actor a screenplay
they have a script and they have the
words the saying they sort of know the
situation maybe they ask a couple of
questions but then it's going back to
they have to create that character what
kind of shoes do they wear or you know
where does they grow up what kind of
school did they go to yet though all
this stuff that's not going to be on
screen because it will show
on screen both in writing and in acting
there's something about the grounding of
a character knowing you know where do
they live what you know what does the
room look like that kind of stuff what
do they books on the shows did they not
have books on the shows do they live
some music were they ever involved in a
crime all the stuff and it just builds
and builds so you have and and you need
that for everybody your minor characters
need to have some interesting stuff
going on otherwise they're just window
dressing them they're not that you know
especially when you have minor
characters who are so interesting
they're almost more interesting than the
main character and you're all and
they're only there for a little bit of
time to make that happen you need to
know a lot about that character the
characters gotta have something going on
maybe they have the secrets that the the
person looking for I just if you're not
writing something and it's fun if it's
not fun you're writing it's not fun why
are you writing it like if it's if okay
I'm writing this I don't enjoy this at
all I'm hoping it sells but it sells
then maybe I'll start like liking
writing like that's a horrible plan that
is you better like writing cuz you're
gonna be doing a lot of it and a lot of
it is not gonna be seen a lot of its
going to get rejected you were and also
you're gonna break I know I've written
some shady stuff my first book will
hopefully be better because of all the
other stuff I've written but it's still
not gonna be the best book I've ever
written because it's my first book but I
I I know their screenplay structure in
it I know like I can feel like I can
feel the first act I can feel this is
kind of what puts this into place here's
the sort of midpoint here's the big
second act plot point now we're just
putting everything down and and it's so
great writing without a budget I don't
have to shoot this I don't have to find
this location I don't want to figure out
somebody who knows how to use drones
like you know it's so much easier when
you just like mlady da da da oh you know
what a house it can be whatever kind of
[ __ ] house I bought because I'm not
gonna [ __ ] find it because I'm not
gonna [ __ ] shoot it yay
that's a nice freedom to have but also
when the audience experience is that
story when you're reading a book you're
in their head in a different place than
when they're watching it on screen most
likely they're not going to jump you
know when they're reading the book and
at all you know that's probably not
gonna happen they'll do that more on
screen they might go oh my god but it's
not gonna be that that visceral you know
when you see an entire movie theater
jump at the same time that's not gonna
happen if they were all reading a book
what do you think the audience wants
from a character I think it's different
for every audience because we are at an
interesting point in history and the
world seems a little extra dark maybe we
don't need more dark stories maybe we do
I think there's something you know
people go to scary movies to be scared
because there's not enough real scary
stuff in their life now there's a bunch
of real scary stuff so I'm wondering if
they still need that scary thing
especially we need to go to movie
theater to be scared which is scary just
to go to the movie theater at this point
in history I think they I think people
need characters who are inspiring but
not in a quote way not in a self-help
way not in a hero but you know small
like I love characters who are in
episodic hsihu you get to see go through
a bunch of stuff and because it's such a
long movie it's an 18 hour movie so you
get to see them go through all these
different things that you wouldn't if it
was in a much shorter amount of time and
and because now your head the whole
here's here's the 18 hours here's this
whole season go watch it and then you
watch it and they're like so how much
longer for the next one three years what
the hell
but you awake because you been you were
into it you were there was nothing else
it was just you and those characters and
on that trip and and and it was fun and
now you want to see what happens though
in the future I think that's a I think
yeah comedy is gonna be more important
than it ever has been and it shouldn't
be looked on it was being frivolous just
because dramas are seen as more
important comedies helped more than
dramas do I think because we need way
more laughing now done we did before not
the drama doesn't have a you know you
want to get lost in their world and cry
your brains out great but I think a lot
more people are gonna be looking for
comedy so we want something in a
character that we can kind of like latch
on to whether we see ourselves in that
character whether that character is
classically good or bad right and do you
think that's why big little lies was
such a well there was such an appeal
because at first you just kind of saw
them is these women that you know oh you
never saw the show okay alright but I I
guess what has what I've always wondered
was why do people have an interest in
spending time with a hit man like I
wrote a story about a guy who kills
people professionally that's his job and
people like him like his character is
likable at some degree the Sopranos yeah
it's I mean yeah it's always Godfather
all of the mafia stuff it's always been
there but it's but when you break it
down when you actually let go bird's-eye
view like why am I so interested in this
guy who runs a crime family who has
anxiety attacks why was it bad son
relations yeah and why why am I going to
watch it when it's on on Sunday night at
the right time like that that is that's
up some never you know it'll never go
away Martin Scorsese's got another one
on deck Oates you know I think the crime
stuff is never gonna go away procedural
or procedure rules have never gone away
and seems like there's even more now
people love the crime stuff
you